[Music]
seaweed is a common ingredient in
japanese cuisine but there's a unique
type growing in the pacific ocean
[Music]
okay
night
[Music]
70 miles off the coast of mainland japan
is the small island of okinawa home to
one of the most unusual farming methods
in the world
[Music]
mr oshiro comes from a seafaring family
and today he is one of the farmers
growing mizuku a special seaweed only
grown in these waters
[Music]
each fall a web of nets are laced with
muzuku seedlings on land then mr oshiro
and his son lay the nuts in rows in the
shallow water
this ingenious system allows the muzuku
to grow sustainably by not creating
additional waste
and when the time is right it is
harvested with two boats in their giant
vacuum
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
today's harvest is then taken to his
factory where it's cleaned weighed and
processed
then it's off to the markets to sell his
underwater treasure
[Music]
muzuku is in high demand
it's packed with nutrients so many
people eat it for a health boost but
that wasn't always the case
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
in recent years mr oshiro has seen a
change in the ocean
so the future of his mazuku is uncertain
[Music]
my
despite the challenges mr oshiro's
dedication proves this work is more than
just a day job
for him it's about maintaining a family
tradition and passing on his father's
respect for the sea
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
you